well maggie and winston proved that in
some cases the pandemic
brings couples closer together they're
getting
married in the finale which is amazing
but as we know weddings never go as
planned
in grey's anatomy what obstacles
should we expect during the finale
obstacle number one uh is winston's
grandmother and obstacle number two
is maggie spock is there anyone here who
objects to this union
oh we do even though they
you know there is a disruption it
doesn't quite go
according to plan um that
they'll be happy the fans will still be
very happy with the outcome
we'd like you to officiate the wedding
oh
really i love that you guys did ask
richard
to officiate the wedding why was he sort
of the perfect
person to do that and will he object
to the objectors oh i love that maggie
asked him to
you know it's been really interesting um
exploring this relationship between or
how this
the relationship has grown between um
maggie and her adopted father which she
met or who she met as
an adult you know um their colleagues
and yet they did sort of have an
immediate
bond there was so much like love and
tenderness between them
right away from the beginning after a
little hiccup i think one of the most
beautiful things about maggie is that
like
she she has taken in everyone has
embraced this new family and
and the weddings are such a great
opportunity to like make the space and
allow people to let people know
um you know how important they are to
you you know and so
i love that that richard was the one
maggie invited to step
in and do that that officiating duty
what's this i hear about you wanting to
marry my little girl oh
god i also have to say congratulations
because you guys got picked up for an
18th
season which is just incredible
first of all what was your reaction
because anthony told me that things
really came down to the wire with that
they did i mean we didn't know
nobody knew um what would happen and
there was just like a while speaking of
wild speculation
you know we were all wondering oh does
it mean something that
all of these characters from the past
are coming back you know what do they
have planned
and and you know for for
closing out the the show which has such
a a long
um and storied legacy and on the one
hand it seemed like a really
great way to close it out because there
was still a lot of story to tell
wrap up and finish so i i was just
excited that
um we'll have a chance um to do that or
or even to continue the story even
further to spin off some stories you
know it's
it's nice to know that like we you know
we didn't it didn't come to an abrupt
end it would have felt very abrupt to me
to be honest you know um and so i'm glad
i'm glad we can sort of tease things out
a little bit longer
you mentioned spin off some stories are
there conversations about potential
grey's
spin-offs should girls yes apparently
there are
i don't know anything about them but yes
apparently there's
there's taco spin out i mean we've done
spin-offs in the past private time
it was a spin-off um and so um
and so and there are just a million
worlds you know that
that could be explored you could see any
of these doctors
uh we could go into the past we could go
into the future there's a million ways
to do it so
so i don't know what they're cooking up
but but
there are just it's a whole universe
it's 17 seasons worth of storytelling i
mean it could be a
patient you know a spin off of a patient
from
you know 10 seasons ago for all we know
so
i don't i don't know but um yeah there's
a lot of potential there
fair to say that you would play maggie
for as many seasons as they asked you to
oh you know maggie pierce and i have
been together for like seven years
and it's been really an incredible
journey
and um but i think you know the way that
we saw some characters
leave because their stories just sort of
came to an end in a really graceful
beautiful way i thought with jackson's
departure
and i mean tragic as it was deluca's
departure
um i think that if
if the story you know wherever the story
goes
um i feel like i i hold on to
to it loosely you know i hold on to
maggie loosely
so you know longevity or whether
you know whether that means a long time
or a short time um
i'm happy to do it right should we
prepare ourselves for any other
departures after the finale i mean you
mentioned
of course jesse left giacomo left greg
has left yeah i'm a little worried
i know wouldn't that be so sad she's
like and another one
and another one
[Laughter]
um yeah you know i'm not gonna tell ya
sorry i was asked earlier um what
one word to describe the the finale
would be and it's
um i the word i used to describe it was
was celebratory
so i think that let's just say this even
if there are departures
you know i think it still feels very
much
um like uh like good news for everybody
i'm glad you didn't die great me too
well changing gears but also speaking of
good news
meredith has recovered from kovid but we
know she goes back to the beach
in the finale what brings her back
to the beach i'm so bad at teasing i
wish that's really clever to say but
like i can't tell you
so i don't know um
uh no i she's got a really really
great reason to go back to the beach
and i think that people will be
happy to see her there okay
are there any uh guest appearances
in the finale perhaps on the beach
perhaps on the beach
um you're gonna have to watch and find
out who would you think
who do you think it would be who's left
who would you like to see
well i always say i always say just you
know i guess
selfishly maggie came to seattle
to know more about her mom and she
obviously couldn't meet her so i would
love to see ellis again i know
as much as you know she's been visiting
um
throughout seasons past i i i wish
maggie and ellis could have a scene
together
is there a big cliffhanger in the finale
yes how are fans gonna feel in those
final moments
i think the fans are gonna feel the way
that we felt
making it which was that you know we
we made it through a tough season you
know tough season of life
where you know which many of us are are
very much still in and
and we managed to find some joy and we
managed to
have some love and yet there was still
heartbreak and yet there is still grief
and and um and i think that
we're we do a great job of sort of
holding all of those things at the same
time
and so i think that um i think the
finale will
will feel as hopeful about the future as
i think many of us
in in real life feel right now that you
know
the the the
that were things will improve and can't
improve and we have seen improvement
we're investing in that
you